ええええええ
goo
me
t
みなさんこんにちは
広島県福山市からやってまいりました節の部分はさとも言います
まずはこちらの画像をご覧下さい
来れば牛乳パックでできた帽子です
僕が今日手に持っているのが現物なんですけども
みてくださいこれ
残念ながら
僕はあったパが大きすぎて入らないみたいです
ここに置いておきますね
この帽子を作ったのは千葉県にお住まいの
椿八郎さんです
なんと椿さんは日常的にこの帽子をかぶっていてしかも tpo に応じてかぶる部を
しよう
今日はこっちにしようとか使い分けています
さらにこのドラえもんの牛乳パックで作った帽子は頭の上に竹子2までついていて
関連血を入れると回る仕掛けになっています
椿さんは
誰かに頼まれてこうした帽子制作をしているわけではありません
一見すると皆さんにとっては無駄なことをしているように思えてくるかもしれません
今日僕がご紹介するのは価値ある無駄というお話です
まず僕自身のことからご紹介します
振り返ってみれば僕はこれまで自分の人生を無駄なことを避けて生きてきました
幼稚園から塾に彼より有名中学校に合格することが僕の人生のゴールでした
小学校6年生の時には毎晩夜中の2時まで勉強していました
今思えば人生で一番勉強していたのもあの時代だったのかもしれません
当時通っていた塾ではこんな風に
塾の先生が新聞紙を丸めて市内のようにして床や机を
直て回るという
まさに受験戦争まっただ中の次会でした
僕は努力の甲斐あって無事中学校に合格することができたんですけども
忠孝一環式の学校だったため6年後には大学受験というさらに大きな壁が待っていまし
た
もう僕の緊張の糸は切れてしまいました
当然最初の大学受験も失敗
イチロー指定のゾーンだ翌年の大学受験では緊張あまり寝付けずなんと数学は19点
もう最悪ですよね
ただ親の手前国立大学に行かなきゃいけないし
もう一度浪人することなんて僕には許されませんでした
僕に残された道はたった一つ
二次試験で逆転合格するしかなかったんです
本屋さんに行って僕が受験できそうな学科を調べていると
4つだけありました
一つは教育学部で体育の先生になるコース
もう一つは美術の先生になるコースと保健室の先生になるコース
そして最後は僕が通うことになる障害のある子どもたちが通う学校特別支援学校の先生
になるコースこの4つだけでした
本屋さんで赤本を手に取った時僕は決めました
特別支援学校のコースは男子が3人女子が23人だったんです
目を閉じると目の前に花園が広がって見えました
僕は必死で逆転合格して無事合格することができました
やっぱりエロの power は強かったんです
卒業後は福祉の世界へ飛び込みました
そこでたくさんの障害のある人たちと出会いました
中でも手をひらひらさせたり同じ場所をくるくる回ったりと奇妙な動きをする
障害のある人たちに僕は御用されました
これはこだわりと言われています
もちろんこだわりは障害のある人に関したことではなくたとえばスポーツ選手が試合中
同じローサを繰り返したり僕たちだってお風呂へ入ったときに体を洗う順番があったり
と
こだわりは誰にでもあります
同じ行動を繰り返しことで自分を落ち着かしているのです
障害のある人に関していえば代わりいく
世界の変化に対抗するため何かにこだわることで自分を防衛していると言えるでしょう
そしてこうしたこだわりが表現活動へ向く人たちもいます
料理人をしていた小林5 o さんはアルコール性神経炎により歩行が困難な状態に
なりました
18歳ごろから書きためたメモ書きを頼りに当時の記憶を呼び起こし
自分が食べた料理のイラストと感想を書き続けています
こちらが小林さんの書いた作品ですめちゃめちゃうまいですよね
すべて上から見た工事で描かれて記憶で書いてます
しかもこの小林さんの作品
どんな風にめくれるしかてまで自分で作っています
書かれてある感想もうまかったとかおいしかったとポジティブな感想ばかりです
ご本人に聞くと後から見たときにいい思い出になるように書いてるんだそうです
そしてこうした小林さんのような録画区次週の表現はアウトサイダーアートと呼ばれ
にが大きな注目を集めています
僕はこうした人たちの生き様に御用され彼だとともに人生を歩んでいくことに決めまし
た
これが今の僕の仕事になっています
ただ障害がないとこうした素晴らしい表現が生み出せないわけではありません
例えばここ札幌でも素晴らしいアウトサイダーアートに出会うことができます
こちらです札幌のあるオタクなんですけどものすごい
デコレーションされた家なんです
しかもですねこのお宅
風が吹くと動くんですがこれがですね
いろいろ回るしか気になっ
使われている材料も
100円ショップで売ってるような料理のお玉やボウルなど身近なものばかりです
おとといも訪問したんですけどどんどんを大きなものにした
see
これを作ったのは北海道警察に勤めていた
田中拓児さんです
田中さんは20年ほど前からお孫さんを喜ばせるために自宅の庭を装飾するようになり
ました
やがてお孫さんたちが成人した後は近所の子供たちが見に来るようになったため
今度は近所の子供たち向けに札幌時計台のミニチュアや回転遊具などを作り続けてい
ます
この店たさんの表現には大きな特徴があります
皆さん何だかわかりますかん
実はですね田中さん警察に勤めていたというだけあって見に来る子どもたちに交通
ルールの大切さを教えるために
すべての玩具の配列を叩き青
つまり信号機の配列にしてるんです
田中さんが大工をしてたという経験はありません
こうした表現に特別な技術は必要ないんです
例えば福岡でサラリーマンをしている
遠藤文宏さんは自分が見た映画や展覧会のチラシその同地に食べた食事のレシートなど
をスクラップし続けています
3年ほど前からはさらに僕のことを追いかけ始め
僕に関する記事も多いんです
これわざわざ
福岡から広島まで行ってきてこの記事を買ってくれてます
誰に見せるわけでもなくただ自分で記録するため盾にしているんです
これが遠藤文宏さんです先ほど僕の追っかけとお話ししましたが実は今日この札幌にも
福岡からはるばる駆けつけてくれています
一番前に座っているのが遠藤さんです皆さん大きな拍手をお願いします
遠藤さんは休みの日はほとんど家にいることなく大好きな展覧会を見て回ったり
僕のことを追いかけるためにフットワーク良く動き続けています
そんな遠藤さんの姿から僕は学ぶことがたくさんあります
まず自分で何かを発信しようと思ったとき
机に向かったままじゃあだ日なんです
自分の足で動いて回ってたくさんのものを見て回ることが大切なんです
見てくださいこのスクラップブックの厚みを
これが遠藤さんの旅の記録でありこの厚みが僕の背中を後押ししてくれます
他人にとっては無駄かもしれないけどやり続けることが大切なんです
こうした表現を発信していくのに特別な道具は必要だ印です
同じ広島県福山して会社員をしている
次の一応さんは自分が好きな作家の人を他の人にも知って欲しいと思い自ら扮装して
自撮り写真を日々インスタグラムにアップし続けています
いまやスマートフォン1台あれば何でもできちゃう
これが杉野さんが変装した有名人なんですけど皆さん誰だかわかりでしょう
これあのジブリの宮崎駿監督です
こちら
これ
わかりますかね結構僕は似ていると思うんですけど
これサザンオールスターズの桑田佳祐さんですね
で最後
これで僕ですね自分で言うのもなんですけどめちゃめちゃ似てます
でこうした表現をですね皆さんはじめたいなと思った時もう歳だからとオップになって
しまうことがあるかもしれません
しかし何かを始める時に遅すぎるということはないんです
車にひかれたような自撮り写真で一躍有名になった
西本公子さんは減税89歳です
なんとこの君こそん写真を撮り始めたのは72歳になってからでしたいっ
ちなみにこの写真なんですが止まっているクーバーに
西本さん倒れ込んでシャッターを押し跡からパソコンで動いているように加工した写真
なのでご安心ください
でこちら
これ
ごみ袋に入った公子さんすすごく自虐的な写真で今世界中に話題になりました
で最後こちらですね物干し竿に釣られちゃってます
左手にはカメラのリモコンが見えてしまっています
いるのは段田さんの服だったみたいなんですけど近所の方がきたらどうしてたん
でしょう
いかがだったでしょうか僕が今日これまで皆さんに紹介した人たちは他人の目や車体の
評価など全く気にしていません
第三者からミート無駄とも思えるようなことを
ただ自分がやりたいからやり続けているのです
そのことが結果として彼らか軍射しの人生をより愉快に豊かなものにしています
僕たちはいい大学に入っていい会社に入って幸せな人生を送っ
それが人生の目標だと教えられてきました
ん
では幸せな人生とは一体何でしょう
お金を貯めて高級ブランド身にまとうことでしょう
必死で働いてリゾート地へ旅行に行くことでしょう
あなたが本当にやりたいことは一体何でしょう
もしかするとこれまであなたが無駄だと思って目を背けてきたものの中にあなたの人生
を変えたりあなたの人生を素晴らしい方向に導くヒントが隠れているかもしれません
たった一度の人生です
自分で本当にやりたいことを見つけて自分の人生を取り戻してみましょうありがとう
ございました
[拍手]